tan pronto la obligación de vacunarse se
anunció los antivacunas se movilizaron
en postdam al oriente de alemania el
partido de ultraderecha a efe de bien
arraigado en la región organizó esta
vigilia
queremos un mundo donde tenemos que
vacunarnos cada seis meses para ser
libres
es un ataque nuestros derechos
fundamentales y para mí es una medida
anticonstitucional a sus vitales en la
región la más resistente a la vacunación
menos del 63 por ciento de su población
cuenta con el esquema completo sin
embargo aquí la gente ya está
acostumbrada a las inoculaciones
obligatorias en el antiguo bloque este
de alemania unas 20 vacunas eran
exigidas me acuerdo bien tactuck lo
hacían con una pistola de inyección o
las más de 30 años después del comunismo
el apoyo a los anti vacunas de algunos
ciudadanos la sorprende por ahora sólo
la vacuna contra el sarampión es exigida
en alemania para niños y algunos
profesionales
y deshacernos de la viruela con la
vacunación obligatoria y podemos ver que
es efectivo también con el sarampión en
un país traumatizado por el nazismo y el
comunismo el tema sigue siendo tabú por
razones obvias dice esta historiadora
los juicios de crímenes de guerra nazi
un juicio especial para los médicos
habían contraído experimentaciones sobre
personas particularmente para
desarrollar vacunas emerson jan cómo se
infectaron con enfermedades para testear
las vacunas dice fatime en el despertar
de una conciencia histórica en los
animales que podría explicar esta
prudencia y sensibilidad
sin embargo frente a la pandemia dos
tercios de la población están a favor de
la obligación de vacunarse la ley podría
hacerlo realidad y ser votada antes de
final de año para ser efectiva en
febrero de 2022